we're playing telephone pictionary
here's how it works we're taking a news
story and having someone draw out that
news story well then take that picture
to someone else and have them try and
guess what the story says then we'll
move on to another person to try and
draw out the same story confused not to
worry but here's today's story tickets
for the new movie went on sale this week
shattering Hunger Games sales records
Star Wars - Darth Vader lightsaber
monies money's money some sort of welder
or radioactive engineers helmet being
hit with a bat oh this is definitely
Star Wars I got my tickets I got my
tickets for Star Wars I'm seeing it
that's a drive no words no one that's
Yoda as Chewbacca money is spewing out
of his lightsaber clearly like ghost cat
money dog cat money is not a news story
are you sure I don't know I'm not sure
I'm not sure of anything right now the
best kind of money cat dog money
Ned wins so far I don't even know where
to sit
I think that's yes cats plus poop face
equals money I mean I wouldn't be
surprised with half the headlines you
see nowadays
now of a game telephone pictionary try
it at home tell us what you get
hopefully not cat poop face money I
don't know
sorry Star Wars